[Music]
and welcome back to the careful boys but
we're exceptionally careful here we got
lawrence cal back in the ceo wow
[Music]
what's up man hey i know that we're a jk
news show so usually usually things are
light but because we're finally back in
here we got to talk about it extra
careful today yeah yeah extra carefully
[ __ ] man i've been [ __ ] itching like
a crackhead to talk about ukraine man oh
dude more like you crack am i right
i got a lot to say so i'll just let you
guys go first
you can't say that yeah what dude what
no
[ __ ] 16 minutes this is a new era i'm
actually here i want to learn because i
i don't i haven't really that's like
that's like breaking down that's like
nikki being like i want to suck your
dick but you eat me out first and i'm
like oh but you just made it so cool
sounding
damn fiber that would be already a
graceful moment but doesn't that make
you go all right i'm gonna eat that [ __ ]
so good so when i do get the dick suck
it's gonna be ten times better yeah but
she just talked about it made me think
visualize it now i want it right now are
we talking about ukraine or russia we're
talking about nikki sucking my dick
which ones you create which one's russia
the dick
oh i think i think we know which one's
russia
as a as a
as a uh
most knowledgeable one of world affairs
here go ahead ask me anything all right
joe
why is why is pooting pooting this
why is mr putin invading ukraine okay so
his name is mr pudding
and um
if you want to
understand the russian side
you have to understand the cold war i
would like to ban you from talking about
the russian side if that's okay yeah can
we yeah so you're bringing cnn you set
up a [ __ ]
emotionally
i've just seen that happening
your knife away yeah that's stupid
you know what's funny though is is like
if you if you look at if you even dare
to look at any other side but the cnn
side you're all of a sudden a [ __ ]
crazy ass and you're a sympathizer yeah
but don't be a sympathizer explore all
different perspectives because i think
all governments are just [ __ ]
different kingdoms
and they're just power they're just
[ __ ] power hungry but you have to
admit this is a unique time because like
during the iraq war nobody was doing
that
yeah because you know for some reason
when we do it it's completely fine yeah
but when other people do it it's hey hey
hey hey hey cause we're sneaky about it
we just bomb you to [ __ ] first and then
put troops on the floor
can you take it back to what you were
going off that uh that cold war tip yeah
so um
i think that a lot of tensions have been
brewing since 1999 when bill clinton
decided to go further into eastern
europe with nato so nato is the north
atlantic treaty organization
basically the cold war war is after
world war ii after world war ii the two
remaining big powers was the usa because
nobody you know destroyed usa soil so
europe was like basically ravaged from
the nazis in the whole [ __ ] war and
um they basically needed a stable
currency in a stable country that they
can rely on so everything got picked to
the dollar and at that time the world
currency was being traded on the dollar
previous to that i don't know what is it
yen before that or something like that
the yen
i don't know about that i don't think so
because china just got opened up to us
even like in the 60s yeah but the that's
the yuan the yen is the japanese one oh
word
but i don't i don't know because i was
just asking the most knowledgeable world
guy in the room but it's all good if you
don't know don't throw me off with these
questions okay i only studied the cold
war trick question yeah yeah okay we're
gonna stay on task
because you're i'm this close questions
what was the population of russia at the
time i'm this close to making up
statistics to sound smart
yeah more made up stuff it was pegged to
the [ __ ] uh the rupees
rupees rupees the that is of course the
zelda currency
okay
that was the wordle word the other day
we only carry 250 at a time right oh
rupee not plural
so after world war ii okay
now it became um basically a battle
between
communism and capitalism the cut the two
concepts and the soviet union which was
russia and all of these states in
eastern europe um they started divvying
it up that's when there was you know the
east and west germany german berlin was
split that's when they had the berlin
wall all this stuff right
and during that time the cold war is
basically a war between these two
countries
who were fighting proxy wars and that's
when we had the vietnam war we had the
korean war we had all these different
wars because
us would be funding the pro-capitalist
side and then the soviet union would be
funding the communist side and this is
where we have states like north korea
this is where we have like you know ho
chi minh you know joining the soviets
and stuff like that and you had all
these proxy wars and that the reason why
that happened is because
a lot of uh
nations that were colonized by europe
when they basically wanted independence
the soviets were like we'll fund you
guys
because prior to that during world war
ii uh a lot of the european powers when
they were spending a lot of money on war
when they're getting [ __ ] you know
busy fighting right there that's that's
when the perfect opportunity came for
all like southeast asia africa all
middle east all them to like come up and
try to build their own nations
and a lot of the european powers
afterwards weren't going to
basically
violate the treaties that they had so
funny enough ho chi minh actually went
to the u.s and
petitioned the u.s government and asked
them for support for independent vietnam
but then the u.s were like we ain't
gonna [ __ ] with the french because we're
friends and that's why they basically
went to the only country that was
handing out ammunition guns and support
to
nations that wanted to become
independent so a lot of these countries
in my opinion would probably not have
been communist
if other if they had support for uh
independence but that's kind of the
story behind those little stories right
and so there's this like this whole
global fight that's going on and the
reason why the us and russia never went
into direct conflict is because they all
had nukes so you'll you'll rarely see or
probably never see
major nations with nuclear weapons going
directly into conflict and that's also
why north korea is trying so quickly to
like get nukes so that they'll never get
[ __ ] with by america
and so this is like the stage of that
kind of tension after the soviet union
fell i think it was in like 1990 or
whatever right
they created that nato organization and
they said yeah look it up because i am
back with dates but they created
make one up check it out 1991 halloween
it was halloween 1998. it was after
christmas december 26th but that was
close
i was on the lunar calendar so that's
years are different man [ __ ] okay so
you're the monkey yeah so then
the nato was created after world war ii
because it was basically all the western
european states plus you know um
you know us and canada saying like okay
there's a soviet threat now because they
want to grow their reach um and then
they all had eastern europe so they're
like well [ __ ] how we gonna
uh
you know fight against this big ass
powerful place and they're like well how
about we all create this like pact where
if they [ __ ] with one of us
like if they invade one of us like
france then we all jump in and that's
what nato is like yes
but then it's like a bar fight
you got my back right that's my buddy
i'm gonna go [ __ ] that
okay cool okay basically so that's what
nato is oh
but the weird thing is it wasn't a gang
but it's a gang
when the soviet union fell and became
russia
and then all these eastern european
nations became independent
the agreement was they're not going to
go more east and to me there was no
reason to have a nato because who's your
threat now if the soviet union was your
previous threat russia is no longer
communist there's no more communist
states in eastern europe who's your
threat there is none but then nato
decides to violate that treaty and go on
and start
including more states or
countries into nato getting closer and
closer to russia so putin he's a kgb
he's an old-school soviet union guy in
his mind from my perspective he still
believes in the glory of russia in those
days
and he still sees the west as a threat
to russia
so
i think in their point of view russian
point of view not mine the argument that
they make is in 1999 bill clinton
started going
closer and closer to eastern europe
adding all these nations into nato when
you agreed not to do that and then it's
like what if i brought mexico under my
team and i started putting missiles
there and then so that's the missile
crisis i mean holy [ __ ] right
and that's kind of what happened during
the cold war
so i think it was romania started
gaining like missiles and um us military
during obama's era uh
they they put us bases in eastern europe
plus missiles facing russia
and then so i think at this point
um it got to the point where okay if if
ukraine joins nato that's in my backyard
that's literally like if i put
nukes in canada i as in putin if i put
nukes in canada facing the u.s it's like
how would you guys if i put in nukes if
i put in nukes like that yeah that was
good thank you um okay and then so
that's that's the backstory of why it
was boiling up it's not yesterday where
it's like look at this crazy dictator
that's just coming in although he is a
crazy dictator that came in
if you can understand the decades of
this brewing then it's like okay
and it wasn't yesterday that uh this
happened obviously like 2014. wait so
are you saying he's justified
[ __ ] no why are you back in a putin joke
well you're giving us putin's
perspective yeah dude
understanding motive isn't justification
but people do that a lot thank you for
pointing that out when we were going
into iraq and saddam was like i swear to
god i do not have weapons mass
destruction and our media was like he's
lying here's colin powell at the u.n we
have the evidence even though he
presented no evidence he just showed
fake photos and [ __ ] before i get
incriminated god damn it before those
people come after me i think first and
foremost war sucks for
well i think first and foremost war
sucks yeah
and the people that get [ __ ] are the
citizens and that that the innocent
victims that's what i yeah that's what i
care about and that's why i hate the
game of thrones meaning i hate the
establishment i hate people that make
these decisions i hate people that are
power hungry and who has to die for it
it's
us it's normal citizens that have to
[ __ ] die for all this [ __ ] so like
you know for me i like to understand how
things brew
why it happens
what perspectives different people have
to justify the means of them invading
other people so
it's like people just think
the the russians are crazy or whatever
it's not i don't think the people there
are crazy because they even protested
against putin i think it's poon and his
handful of homies
that are stuck in a soviet-era mindset
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd is not what you feel it's about what
you do not feel such as stress anxiety
pain and all the feels that make you go
and you know one of the fields that make
me go
which is anxiety or like a lot of high
energy
is caffeine i didn't realize how
caffeine sensitive i was and i like to
drink a lot of coffee teas all that
stuff delicious when it comes to night
times i can't go to sleep man
i'll be tossing and turning thinking
about who's gonna come to my funeral
whoa who's gonna go skating with me
who's gonna go if i had to [ __ ] do a
world tournament of juggling who's gonna
show up and show up for me yeah that's
hard to sleep when you think about
juggling it's very difficult so
what i have to do is
basically i have my nighttime routine i
have to unwind from my anxiety feels
okay i got too much hypeness i have
adrenaline so what i use is my feels put
a couple of drops on my tongue this is
my system 30 minutes to an hour before i
sleep and then i start to chills i add a
little bit of meditation you know i
might get that [ __ ] water bowl like
the monks use and go wow
you know what i'm like
sound bath
get the dolphins
you know like
all that stuff and then i start to chill
and i fall asleep
feels so dope because it's premium cbd
and if you're like yo that sounds scary
well there's no need to because they got
a customer service hotline you can call
them and you'd be like yo i've never
taken this before or you could be like
man i'm like 280 pounds how many drops
should i take and they'll walk you
through from beginning to end and if you
sign up for the membership you also save
money and you can cancel at any time
anytime baby so they got a special deal
for you guys if you become a member
today by going to feels.com
off the record you'll get 50 off your
first order plus free shipping that's
l f-e-a-l-s dot com slash off the record
to get 50 off plus free shipping so
become a member today because you get to
save money remember i told you to cancel
anytime okay go to fuels.com
off the record to get 50
off plus free shipping go take care of
yourself man what feels and also
if you do believe that they should have
stuck to the nato treaty agreement
and then if you see that the u.s is a
threat threat and they violated that
then in his perspective it is justified
because it's uh it's like you're
basically violating what we agreed upon
joe what can i do right now can i put a
flag in my like little profile or
something like that change my profile
pic to the ukrainian flag what can i do
what kind of how can we help you get a
nobel peace prize for that apparently
i mean
it's up there
they're giving those away huh
i think what we can do is clap for now
do you guys remember in 2014 when
ukraine um was going through somewhat of
a civil war a color revolution a color
route no they were actually going 24
yeah 2014 there was that right so um
there's two regions in eastern europe uh
eastern ukraine who are ethnically more
russian
um it's like
i can't even pronounce it but it's like
don't test or some [ __ ]
don't ask dog tasks but i'm probably
pronouncing wrong anyway that's pretty
good though thank you from how i
remember it being spelled don't task
but those are the and then there's
crimea which is like a small little
like a not not an island but like a like
a bay
and those areas
the russians came in and then their
justification was
oh we recognize these states because the
red rebel fighters here want
independence so we're coming in and
we're we're helping him support that
from
their narrative is ukraine
if ironically is white supremacist with
with the with the jewish president but
they call them white supremacists
because i thought that was weird and
they say that they're puppets to the u.s
and they need to be liberated yeah
that's their narrative
and then so oh yeah and i'm only saying
their narrative because we already know
our narrative our narrative is you know
putin's just a crazy [ __ ] coming
in and
trying to take over the country of
ukraine and we gotta fight for democracy
and freedom so what's the us doing to
help ukraine giving them weapons weapons
yeah and economic sanctions yeah
to russia
but what sanctions really do that i
think is is whack like in the history of
sanctions is they just [ __ ] with the
people like what we've been talking
about escalate war
yeah you're talking about constricting
the population from food and supplies
and medical services is that the only
fans revenue from like russian girls
really that's the worst thing you can do
yeah
but then they they they reactivated it
after they were like
they're not a threat
everybody wins
even ukrainians went from that one
only fans does not have a red line they
will always go back because remember
yeah yeah yeah maybe they got cards
they're like you cannot do porn on here
and then everyone's like hey [ __ ] you
and they're like hey we're bad now
yeah they turned off uh pornhub too
they turned off pornhub for all russian
users that's how you stop the wario
that might be how you start the war the
soldiers are just like way more powerful
at war though because they can't jack
off oh that's interesting
is that true though when you have like
you keep your sperm you're just stronger
that's how that's how america was
founded bro
we had a boxer on and he said is that
true that's what he said that's what
brandon lee said he didn't really say
that but aren't you more aggressive when
you're horny as [ __ ] and you haven't
been [ __ ] for a while that's why like
that's why christian wars are so much
more
the brutal were brutal very true because
they just had celebs do you don't want
to see the mormons at war that's why
i've never gone to war yeah yeah don't
[ __ ] anything up we can take salt lake
city
they'll [ __ ] anything up or they'll [ __ ]
everything a buddhist a buddhist war
that's why you can't take utah and
settlers of catan
you can't [ __ ] with utah at all you
touch it it's immune this is god's land
so who's winning the war right now
well dude there's a couple things going
on right so like our media wants us to
believe in what our side wants which is
what joe's talking about like hey um the
ukrainian people are so or the ukrainian
military is actually outwitting putin's
shitty military like home alone too and
[ __ ] right
but throwing pearl necklaces on the
ground
but
flips the tank the russian military is
[ __ ] crazy right like if putin wanted
to he could just go level ukraine but he
doesn't want to do that because he wants
to do what he did with crimea which is
crimea take it over and then use their
critical infrastructure to bolster his
military and all kinds of [ __ ] right
yeah and if you believe his perspective
or the narrative that the russians are
saying they're there to liberate not to
murder and massacre because they see
them as their same people and
the way that i've basic that i know
about ukraine and russia is um it's like
canada and the us it's very close like
maybe even closer because in their uh
royal family or just even in ethnically
they're like almost the same people
yeah so it's really it's like north and
south korea it's like same people but
just like a little bit different
um just not politically but
the the crazy thing is though is if
some of the people on ground are saying
that the soldiers who are deserting they
they didn't even know that they were
coming in for that so that's one of the
weird things russian soldiers russian
soldiers are coming out
um they're deserting because they didn't
know that they're coming out i'm gay
that too
that's another new story
they're coming out of their tanks like
i'm calling now that's just cnn millions
of russian troops are coming out on the
front lines it's pretty brave though
because you get emotional and [ __ ] do
dances
my soldiers are coming out
[ __ ] this for man
they're deserting so the cnn uh
perspective really is nothing more than
putin's just [ __ ] nuts that's all no
i don't know man um i i don't really
like it's harder because when i watch
there's joey and putin on the same
people
basically no more joe rogan stuff i
would never even be talking about it
it's hard to watch it because i think in
our media
um or any like mainstream media whether
it's russian media or us we have to like
deconstruct it like you watch it and you
go what are they trying to do and then
so what i've been trying to do more now
is that um there's more independent
sources that are just
taking footage and then they're not
giving you an opinion they're just
saying this is what happened like uh
these tanks were deserted or they're
showing footage of it but then now our
media has so many like different biases
and opinions
that it's more like a
it's more like what do you call it like
there's a narrative attached to it and a
goal and then so that makes it difficult
for me to like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
well because we've been lied to so much
look at the ghost of kiev and all this
other stuff yeah dude they want to
construct this narrative where people
look at what's going on and go okay
ukraine is super strong and maybe that
will keep um
um
russia at bay while we get these
sanctions through and then maybe russia
will pull back because that's what
ultimately what our
military wants is for russia to pull
back because they see the folly of this
yeah that's the different perspectives
right so our media is trying to push
that perspective because our media
largely helps the cia we all know that
right operation mockingbird all this
kind of [ __ ] like they're in there to
try to drive home the narrative of our
government for for imperialism so
you know there's a lot going on
unfortunately that that you know and i'm
just talking about perspectives so but
you know it doesn't matter because
everyone will think i agree with that
now so so you're saying that russia's
right
it all goes back full circle the best
but once again once again all i care
about is the people who are stuck in the
middle i think what sucks is if you see
who's the ones fighting you know it's
like
they always say like young men die for
old men making decisions in war right
it's all these old [ __ ] guys that are
disconnected living in their safe like
[ __ ] like castles right except for
the president of ukraine he's badass
like he's with the people at least he
appears you know he appears but that was
that was old that was another thing
we're really saying out of the country
just making videos he was an actor they
have footage of him in bulletproof vests
and [ __ ] from like old movies and
he was too i think yeah he was a
comedian he was
kind of kind of funny yeah it's pretty
cool
it's fine it's chill but that but they
use those photos and they say this is
him at the front lines with the soldiers
but he wasn't so those are all their
photos so once again it's like it's like
they're trying to construct this
narrative an old war comedy
i'm not that old because he's not an old
guy but you know what i mean like it's
it's not it's older than that
he looks like he's 17.
why is he laughing in the front lines
i think you know why is it going we're
[Laughter]
that's the other thing did you see that
oh did you see the model um she's
holding an airsoft gun but they say that
she was she's like
that was good same [ __ ] that was fake
too it was an airsoft gun oh and the
island was fake island snake island uh
russian warship go [ __ ] yourself what
about the uh the guy that got ran over
in the car by the train that was really
a truck that
[Music]
it was a ukraine truck they said it was
a russian truck but it came out to be no
[ __ ] way yeah
random over was a ukrainian
what get the [ __ ] out that's what i
heard but who knows that doesn't happen
and then that missile that hit the
building
no i'm just kidding
what god damn i'm kidding about the
missile but no it was a [ __ ] fake i
think um what the [ __ ] what i'm happy
though is that is that
it's just a it's just a pool noodle the
whole time you're saying this is fake
yeah it's an airsoft gun
that's katniss no she's not at the front
lines or anything like that are those
shooting glasses anyway well it's like a
social influencer post for like airsoft
ads yeah really that's crazy
i think what's cool though is with
social media
we're
we're more globally connected and what
i've noticed now like stupid
well yeah yeah but the but the cool
thing is that
you know we don't see them as like these
russian foreign
threats we see them as human beings now
and then i think russians see you know
everyone else and you see them
protesting they wouldn't be able to do
that like protesting st petersburg and
[ __ ] moscow they wouldn't be able to
do that back in the day they'll just get
shot up those are also fake photos that
cnn has could be the real question is
what does hasabulo think about all this
have you seen those memes where they're
trying to shoot they're like i don't
want to kill hasbula
that's what came out of it yeah you sent
that to him
that was great
that's a great view this wesley snipes
with the tears yeah
he doesn't want to kill blue juice or
some [ __ ] yeah but haven't you guys
noticed though
a lot of people aren't playing into this
whole um good guy bad guy narrative
anymore i hope so try to play that in
the very beginning did you see how
they're like once again we are going to
spread democracy we need to protect them
they probably they try to play that game
and it got shut down like immediately
bro they're just saying the other night
like we got to fight russia over here so
we don't fight them at home and i'm like
bro that's what they said in iraq
they're using the same playbook it's so
[ __ ] annoying yeah well i think we
might need a part two of this discussion
though so you're saying
[Music]
[Music]
you